[Música]
o dólar a vocês para que entrem por aqui
como foi pra mim esse ano nós já vamos
treinar também isso o porquê e posso
começar a minha toca por ser ou não ser
eis a questão é tão simples quanto isto
é tão simples que é só escolher e é tão
simples como parece não estão
complicadas
todos nós temos nós todos os sonhos do
mundo mas não foi não basta só ter
porque se não mostrar nada é então nós
queremos conversa mas sócrates lança
amanhã e eu perguntei qual é o vosso
amanhã é um caso por aí
no fundo a minha toca vou abrir a porta
para descolar da minha história mas
espero se calhar abrir um pouco que seja
uma janela na nossa história pra vocês
também perceberem o que vocês querem
fazer com a nossa vida
posso começar por uma fase menos o
obrigava a foto traz peças e apurar o
caso por aí
[Música]
no fundo é isso foi publicada no
facebook por uma amiga já não é minha
amiga com maior mas basicamente o que eu
tenho do algarve aqui outras vezes aqui
é o objetivo de vida porque eu com 14 15
anos e agora tem 26
basicamente embora não seja uma frase
tão bonitinho visível de maneira mais
ninguém é mais romântica mas viver a
vida à minha maneira de ser feliz com
ela e para explicar muito desse conceito
vou deixar aqui
se eu falar aqui um cigano 14 que no
fundo é o meu pai e foi a primeira vez
que eu cortei o cabelo eu sou vasco -
disse a mãe
não sou o cientista e frei infantis mas
é isso que eu pretendo mostrar é um
pouco mais da parte emocional a
partilhar o que alguns jogadores e
aquilo que nos faz trabalhar mesmo
momento mais do que qualquer um qualquer
outra coisa e não podia falar da minha
história sem falar do meu pai não falar
do meu pai mas deixar meu pai do momento
presente e minha mãe não está porque não
há cabelo brilhante mas devia estágio na
foto mas no fundo é um bocado isso é que
eu fiz o cruzeirinho normal
fui para a universidade segui o meu
irmão seguiu criando design gráfico mas
sim suas tecnologias muito rapidamente
para tentar avançar muito
acabei por ir para miami castel relação
mês
fui depois para a química na
universidade domingo porque queria fazer
transferências nível informático quero
que as pessoas diziam que tinha saído
mais em química contida joanita trá lá
lá vão quase oito anos portanto é é a
nossa história no fundo da bolsa total
mas mas acaba por não tem que ia e no
fundo é um cara por ele fui pra química
mudei pra ele não pode informar como a
ciência da computação
não fiz nada da vida sem um salto grande
e conseguir fazer essas coisas todas
depois no fundo tem quatro anos na
universidade do minho e sofre uma
cadeira e não foi esta certeza mas de
qualquer das formas basicamente foi isso
que depois nem coragem para enfrentar
senhora e sua esposa dizer que o facto
que eu queria dizer gráfica então voltar
em outra vez fui fazendo específica não
consegui a primeira a conseguir
assegurar com o site tem que dizer quero
fazer bem ea e no fundo entrou em design
gráfico mas depois passar o três anos em
design gráfico já estava quase a seguir
o terceiro ano seguinte afinal o
primeiro da lista
então os pais onde afinal o que eu quero
é que eu ensinei garagem
basicamente tudo condição e um centavo
investido lado o amigo meu portão o
campeão e depois eu fiquei a pensar
porque era bom ficou e deixam o corpo e
eu então fria tarde deste lado
basicamente isso na minha garagem
não tenho espaço se tu não tá fácil a
ganância basicamente mas o que eu fazia
era mandar um cabo do 3º andar filme
rússia andar mandava um carro descendo
para poder legislar e mesmo na minha
garagem o que eu queria porque eu sou
muito assim eu faço e tem que fazer é
convencer ou então não faço e vocês
sabem eu diria o outro com o mesmo as
barbas são feitas aqui buscar uma toalha
500 e mandar no microondas e vasco que
me dizer aos meus clientes a outra
minuten disse que domingo vamos é ter um
serviço combinado
daí passou a trabalhar com o pedro remy
e lá fui quatro noites eu fazia uma
espécie de noite mais bateria e teve o
prazer trabalhar com esses senhores
depois o tal espaço quando meu colega me
cortou o cabelo que era tudo um tapa em
construção é uma coisa assim mesmo
absurda nos através do animal
meu pai vocês falem bem plantado é o
medo de coisas em um ambiente que o que
tá todo mundo esteve muito confiantes
que se gastar quase que me entenderão
toda uma possibilidade da oportunidade
é um momento muito bom no natal
em conversa com dois colegas meus que
são aqui os meus não vou receber 22
clientes não era o pai eo avô e é isso
mesmo que eu porque uma parte depois
veria que é parte social é o os meus
clientes são todos meus amigos no fun
dias e alguns deles estão aqui alguns já
foram meus clientes no fundo eu tenho no
meu sucesso muito quase que mostra se
deus for milhão
o filme mais que eu ame mesmo foi
iniciado mas no fundo em seu c e esta
parte que o que eu gosto muito
outro momento em que um cliente meu
chegou à casa da avó e avô um pouco com
com lágrimas nos olhos o fazem lembrar
muito o vovô neste momento e foi o
quarto deus jogou 11 tenta antigo de
olho pitt disse que um fato o avô teria
todo o gosto em que o universo o que ele
fez com muito jeito naquela altura e no
fundo é isso é por mais que o corte
esteja lá e eu adoro e e nem mesmo os
cool e ter um carro caro e esse facto
dizendo que eu tenho capacidade técnica
é tudo o resto é é o meu facebook
instagram e eu dou mais valor às
descrições do problema das faltas as
fotos são incríveis e e no fundo é uma
oportunidade vocês vão usar no momento
mas a descrição val muito mais do que
falta conquistar lá tive a oportunidade
virá o manda tirar um curso de dois dias
com um bar da capital e é uma das minhas
bandeiras e um pouco menos das mais
conceituadas do mundo
tive essa oportunidade mas porque o
fundo sou eu que vou à procura das
coisas ninguém mais vai trazer a casa de
certeza absoluta que confirme a
trabalhar no porto estava trabalhando em
braga estava a trabalhar no porto
trabalhou também na suíça como vai ser
convidado e todos menos duas semanas
isso foi quando fui à a a uma convenção
nem inglaterra e aek pessoa se tornar
toda no percurso que que agora no fundo
meu futuro é a oportunidade de fazer
essa hipótese uma barreirinha onde fez
uma uma mtur
várias baterias cinco episódios 5
vermelhas diferentes mostrar o que o
portugal um tempão que também tem tanto
de nós e do nosso país não foi minha
disciplina pois passaram uma coisa maior
foi demorada mas sim nos meus pais
pensei em tudo que eu vim a deixar tudo
para trás em portugal porque fui viver
bem no nível no fundo fui trabalhar aqui
e aí que estou trabalhando neste momento
é uma das baterias uma das melhores da
europa conseguiu em todo mundo são os
que vão da austrália vão da américa eram
os três dias e fator é mesmo muito muito
gratificante poder trabalhar nestes
neste espaço
ninguém foi buscar a casa eu fui à
convenção e uma das três candidaturas
uma prendesse durante muito tempo porque
o facto não queria passar por essa por
essa parte já tinha passado já cortava
tv eu mandei pavor banheiro não dou
muita importância para ver de fora
porque podem não conhecer as pessoas
então posso mandar em construção mas
acaba por ser um cara engraçado a e
manda aí depois promovê lo porque sei
que meu grupo é muito forte mas eu
acabei o tre é facto o meu cabelo é o
flamengo mas no fundo meu cabelo e eu
estava cortando o cabelo mas mas
basicamente é um cargo eletivo cabelos e
também tomando como modelo porque a
convenção lá no era no resgate fui lá
conversão timão que já deu soco time
campeão em palco e teve a oportunidade
de conversar falar de explicar a minha
paixão o que é que eu não via nunca foi
o dinheiro principalmente a certeza
porque estava ganha muito dinheiro aqui
mas fui para lá porque é o futuro o
futuro é que todas as coisas e no fundo
e ouviu que o que eu tenho alguma coisa
e combinam com a tranqüila
isso foi uma convenção em lisboa é
basicamente para terminar com uma
perspectiva de investir uma frase que é
nossa maior capacidade técnica é o saber
ouvir isso não foi feito pelo cientista
foi problema vai ser campeã e facto pra
mim um compacto de avião não é um bom
quarto campeão se sabe que não é que o
concluindo que viu mas neste contexto o
que eu quero dizer é que durante 24 anos
da minha vida que eu tive no fio da
navalha mas base em miami volta a
lembrar da nossa capacidade técnica a
melhor é saber ouvir e eu estava com
você só vai servir vocês próprios porque
não houve branco muito tempo das duas
uma ou ficamos no fio ou se devemos
ouvir e tomar o controle da vale
o bilhão
[Aplausos]
[Música]